hello my name is Michael angstrom I'm
heading up SAS internationally and the
question of us is what is the main
reason why Europe is in crisis while the
world is interconnected as we all know
and that means that we are facing risks
now that are global in nature and they
impact everyone but they are common like
demographic issues to aging to health
issues unemployment the fact that we
have changing demographics with with
higher burdens with the body deficits
the good news are that in an
interconnected world we can actually
draw on the collective knowledge we have
all unique abilities to innovate to
drive the gamma forward and that I think
starts very much with the debate here in
the horse the opening session did not
only talk about the global risks but
also the opportunities arbitrary shape
the world based on Big Data basal
hyper-connectivity and based on ability
to draw on the collective knowledge to
actually come up with innovative
solutions as when to the digital age and
look at the bright future together